all right so I can very vividly remember
my first day working at hotels.com
my manager he sits me down and he
explains what problem we're gonna try
and solve and he starts off by
explaining the concept of metasearch and
the idea is that someone can go to a
website like TripAdvisor punching where
they want to go how long they want to be
there and they'll compare a number of
different options from different travel
agencies so as I was preparing for pi
data today I punch this in and I get
back these few properties now the
resolution here is awful but you might
be able to see that there's different
travel agencies within a property and
the ordering of those travel agents is
at least in part determined by how much
they're willing to pay for the privilege
so the fact that experience number one
here suggests that they were willing to
pay direct advice and more than we were
and on the flip side at the Ventura and
Mercer where we're in number one that
suggests that we were going to bed more
in this mini auction and our problem was
that we were going to try and work out
the expected value of a click on every
property with a view to automatically
sending this to TripAdvisor now at this
point I have a realization and I
realized in my career so far University
my jobs I've never actually made a model
that's done anything so
I filled out Excel sheets I put like
columns and databases I have made
recommendations but there's always been
a human in the loop
looking over the model shoulder making
sure that what it's doing is reasonable
and the idea of this safety blanket
being taken away terrifying I can feel
my hands start to climb up a little bit
like at the moment Ashley but my manager
you see he wasn't them he explained this
is an incredibly complex problem the way
that people want to travel varies
lottery time through location and from
person to person and if that weren't
enough it's also just a very important
problem TripAdvisor and similar sites
are a big source of revenue and profit
for Expedia and at this point my
climbing hands have progressed into
full-on flop sweat my hands are shaking
I can feel like my gut be arranged and
to top it all off he explains the
mistakes in this space is super
expensive if we submit a wrong set of
bids and we over predict then we can
lose finance reductively huge sums of
money before were able to correct him
and honestly I was contemplating just
walking away at this point I felt so
stressed and it truly was a very
stressful journey to getting to a
successful model along the way I need a
number of really high-impact
mistakes and my hope is that today
you'll be able to learn from those
mistakes and avoid them in your own work
so everything I'm going to say is
colored by my context but it should
apply to your work if your models fit
into like these kind of three different
things whether your model should have to
carry out some important task well that
might be spending millions of dollars
advertising spend or it might be pairing
some feature on your website that's very
important to your customers secondly
you'd expect these models to be hard to
understand they should be modeling a
complex domain or they should operate at
some scale which is just superhuman so
think even a very simple model at
Twitter is going to be very complex for
a human to understand and finally these
models will operate semi autonomously
either due to the scale or the way you
have to deploy you can't have a person
step in you can't have them a person
looking at
predictions and then saying don't do
that so we have to be able to trust
they're willing to do the right thing in
a wide range of different situations so
to sum up and this will be super
important throughout the rest of the
talk
we need these models to be powerful
enough to do that which we wish them to
do but we need them to be reliable
enough then my blood pressure can stay
under 200 over 90
not that yet so I leave this meeting and
I've sat down in front of my computer
I'm thinking to myself well I never saw
this this problem before but I'm not so
green behind the ears I don't know how
to do data science so I'm just going to
stick to what I know and I'll be fine so
I'm going to take what I've called here
the fairy tale approach to data science
I'm going to go up I'm going to get some
interesting data I'm going to want to
talk to Tripp advisor to our bookings
team I'm gonna want to talk to our
lodgings team to find us much about
these properties as possible I'm gonna
mash it all together do some cross
validation so okay fold time series
these kind of things I'm going to use
some era metric like our MSE of a
revenue per click and then finally just
do a whole kill a series of cool things
like stuff you might have heard of today
do try Cadbury's try some feature
engineering say some parameter
optimization now I've called this the
Fairy Tail approach to data science not
because I wish to be critical it
actually has a very strong central
message I hope that you're all doing
something that looks kinda sorta like
this and in the same way fairy tales
give us a very strong ethical message
they give us a clear idea of what it
means to act right and to be a good
person but if you try to live your
entire life by fairy tale ethics you'd
find that super limiting as you enter
complex adult nuanced situations you
need a complex adult nuanced approach to
data science ethics but also data
science and if we set off with good
intentions and a simple approach will
quickly ruin to you failures and I'm
going to talk about these four main
categories today they were by no means
my only failures but they're just the
ones which looked
on the slides really so I'm gonna talk
about looking at single era metric
failing to account for all goals
building a model I couldn't talk to and
interacting poorly with humans so I set
off it seems like a phenomenal idea to
choose rms CEO for revenue per click and
optimize that as much like humanly can
and it was really nice to begin with if
I wanted to try out a new modeling
approach new features new parameters I
just like scoop and mullet I jerk him
into cross-validation and I just choose
the one that ends up looking the best
and at this stage I'm feeling pretty
cocky feeling pretty good about life my
arm I see is looking healthy and beating
the models that already exist and then
we try launching it and the performance
is absolutely shockingly catastrophic
before it's like we're losing money hand
over fist in one place and then we try
it again and we're getting no volume
somewhere else I'm thinking to myself
what what's gone wrong so I go back and
I look at my models and I see that yes
my rmse was getting better through time
but I was doing a lot of damage to other
metrics so my ma II was getting worse I
was getting quite weird shapes of arrow
distributions and I was having a lot of
overall bias on the worst day the worst
day of it all I discovered that a model
that predicted zero profit for a click
on any property was actually getting a
better rmse than my champion model and
like it's an awful model right but just
because of how our machine works out it
looked better and if this weren't enough
the models weren't just not accurate
they were also shockingly unreliable so
I have here on screen a plot of
predictions from different
cross-validation sets so this is one
train set that I've cut up in a number
of different ways
and you can see that the models ended up
with predictions that just look wildly
different they're different in terms of
central tendency they're different in
terms of variance the difference in
terms of shape so this is just a
nightmare to validate if I run my model
again and I get a totally different
result how do I know if that's just
natural or like the model doing this
thing
or if that's a problem that's been
introduced and I probably could have
lived with this if the models improve
themselves trustworthy but the slightest
amount of bad data or sometimes just
like you look at the model rung and he
would explode and for no reason you'd be
losing money quite quickly and that was
just incredibly stressful experience I
hasten to point out all of these graphs
are fake data for illustrative purposes
so what's the solution
the solution is to realize that our MSE
or whatever error metric you want to use
is only ever going to be an
approximation to that which you care
about and like all good approximations
it has its use cases and but if you try
and stretch it too far you'll end up at
educators damaging yourself the solution
that we came up with was to have a
standard set of Diagnostics that
captures everything that we care about
in model performance so things like
stability distribution of errors overall
bias for us this was the Jupiter
notebook that you could just hit and it
would generate all these graphs but
whatever stack you want in the best of
all possible worlds these notebooks
would not only have what's important but
also guide you into what does good look
like like what's a reasonable level of
stability and if you want to be proper
Northstar about it they give you a way
to make decisions so you'd have maybe
red amber green on every one of these
metrics it's like red red red really a
good set of Diagnostics should be simple
to run easy to say for reference and
simple to just share in common it's
incredibly liberating when you try it
out a new set of things to just get an
output get it in Dropbox send it to your
team and then get feedback on it in a
way that everyone already understands
and if you take nothing else from this
talk today I'd recommend it to be this
just make some Diagnostics don't books
even if they're very simple will be very
useful for you however it's important to
remember that the purpose of this is not
to get a stack ranking of models by
their very nature by their very purpose
the goal is to be forcing to making
explicit
trade offs you're never gonna make a
model that's better everything you're
gonna have to trade off accuracy for
bias bias for stability these kind of
complex decisions and there is no best
way to make these I'd like the best
trade off is going to vary between
companies between industries between
teams and to give you an example we
start off as quite a small team with a
lot to do sorry so it made sense for us
to trade off accuracy for stability so
that we could get the maximum bang for
buck but now as we're growing as a team
and we're still hiring it makes sense to
try and maybe reduce some of that
stability and juice up the matrix but
create a bit of stability for a bit more
performance and see if we can get better
results one of the big questions around
diagnostics is what should you include
there's an obvious trade-off here
between speed and depth the more you add
the slower gets the less likely your
data scientists are to run the
Diagnostics a good algorithm that we
found is to start with the kitchen sink
approach just check everything you might
think is even conceivably useful in
there and then through time you'll just
naturally trim out stuff that you don't
use once you've run this four or five
times you'll find this like three core
graphs that you look at every time and
the rest is just rubbish you just get
rid of it and then on the spin side
every time you see a problem with models
in production that you didn't expect you
go back and you try and find something
that would have alerted you to that in
advance and you put down your
Diagnostics and that saved me more times
than I can count in this process so that
was phase one I go back to the basics I
maybe make a few different trade-offs
and now I have a stable model it's not
as accurate but it performs much better
and I'm feeling like king of the world
at this point I truly am in a few months
I've come in I've revolutionized it and
then the revenue they were making from
that a search is way up seriously like
giant hat time but then like a few weeks
later I'm in a meeting with someone from
finance
and they look at me and they say isn't
it awful isn't it awful that clickshare
on TripAdvisor is way down and I look at
him when I go but but yeah but revenues
way up and he looks at me and he's like
yeah but click shares way down and we
stare at each other a mutual bafflement
for about five minutes and then a few
days later I'm talking to someone who's
in charge of say the American
destination trying to get people to go
to America and he looks at me and he's
like oh isn't it awful that revenue to
America's way down I mean like him and
like ever revenue off rolls way up and
he looks at me and he's like yeah but
remember revenue to America's way down
and we stare at each other in mutual
Battlement for five minutes and after a
few weeks of this it starts to sink
through that actually maximizing revenue
from metasearch what I thought was my
goal obviously wasn't enough for this
model not to be a failure the reality is
that there was a whole host of possible
side objectives that people around the
company could have had so I have here on
screen there like things that I thought
about the top of my head sending people
to America sending people from America
getting new properties to sign up
getting new people to join hotels that
come now what's really interesting about
these is that they're not just purely
random side doors they're actually work
against the main goal if I was aiming to
just maximize revenue per search I won't
give a damn about getting new customers
into the business right I'm gonna want
my core customers go into my core
properties and that's how I'm gonna make
the most revenue but actually I have all
these side constraints the place
limitations on how I can go about them
and not being aware of them caused me to
fail quite horrendously and the most
galling part of the whole thing was that
failure existed in that very first
meeting with my manager as soon as I
stepped out of there we've even before I
started typing I'd failed I should have
said look no I get that this is a simple
way that you're explaining it to a new
joiner but there's actually a much
richer context here and then going to go
around I'm going to talk to a wide
variety of different stakeholders build
their trust understand what's important
to them
and by this you don't have to be best of
friends with your state covets you just
have to know them well enough you know
what's important to them and you know
why it's important and they have to know
you well enough that they can trust that
you can do that now once you've got all
of this information it's important to
make trade-offs like you can't make
everyone happy with this model just like
sometimes it's impossible you have to
decide what is and isn't important
and that's probably gonna need a factor
if who's asking how valuable it is to
the business and honestly just can you
do it and you separate this out into
maybe four or five goals that you're
going to achieve and you explain clearly
the language that people understand why
you're not going to be able to achieve
that side dollars and maybe you tell
them that in the future you'll try and
get to them like you just have an
understanding with them that even though
you think that's important you can't do
it right now and that will prevent so
many stones being thrown at you in the
future
lastly it isn't enough to simply be
aware these things exist you also need
to make sure you're gonna do something
about them right if we just set off
saying nice party cues we're not gonna
get anywhere first I find the most
effective way was to add these things to
our Diagnostics notebooks so each one of
the side goals would have two or three
charts to see how well we're doing on
each different section so you might have
overall accuracy accuracy or new
properties accuracy on all properties
that kind of thing quite similar to the
presentation earlier on today about the
preventive bias in machine learning
making sure that each of these segments
is well represented in your model
so go back to basics start up again
another three months of my life gun and
I said about remaking this model and
this time we have great success so I now
know what I'm doing I've got a decent
foundation and they've got a good model
we're making money hand over fist and
I'm feeling great this time Jane had and
this feeling actually does last for a
few weeks
all is looking very healthy well then
frustration starts to grow because I
realized that it's very difficult for me
to be talking to these models what do I
mean by that so I have here on screen
the venturi and Mercer from earlier it's
a real screenshot from our website now
if I'm going to start talking about
revenue per click I don't have much of
an intuition for what that means as
someone who travels a lot he works in
the travel industry who actually works
in this problem I don't really have a
feel for where this property should be
on a revenue per click basis and he's
got quite a high price per night looks
very nice has great reviews but like how
to aggregate that and this starts off a
little force training but every time I
realized I also can't talk to my model
analytically so I have here on the right
and purely illustrative distribution of
revenue per click that we might observe
through properties and most of the time
someone's going to click on a property
and not convert so they'll be in this
big spike at zero and then occasionally
someone will come on I'm not convert and
then they'll be way down this slab but
you might imagine this is a difficult
distribution to work with it's gonna
take a long time before the central
limit theorem kicks in for this and
across the next few months we experience
severe problems on both accuracy and
stability so the first real issues that
we were having was that it's very
difficult to diagnose their model how do
you build a hypothesis what the models
doing badly if you don't have an
intuition for their domain and you don't
have good analytical tools and unlike
the fluke shot that you hit upon
something to improve the model with how
do you tell that you've made it better
you've got such a high bay
line of arrow that it's just very
difficult to see if you're making things
better and then as we were meetings like
trying to discuss what the important new
features again to the model were I
realized I just had no idea like I look
at the victory in Mercer I'm like what's
an important feature for revenue per
click oh I don't know I also just don't
have any prior knowledge that I can
bring about the model tells me that
early breakfast is very important for
revenue per click I don't know how to
and then finally it was very difficult
to build trust in these models so for
the same reasons that it's hard to
diagnose it's tell to it's difficult to
know whether the model seen well in
production and whether I can identify
whether something is government and
through time this just became a drag
like we're having fewer model iterations
our test and learn was slower and we
were having to rely on like full a/b
test more and just three times needs to
improve as much as we wanted to so the
solution was to go back to the problem
and just to think about it a bit more a
bit more deeply I might not have a good
sense for revenue per click but I
probably have a pretty good feel for
other things about its property so if I
look at this very high price by night
this three is five six I can't have a
reasonable guess that if someone comes
on to the property and converts there's
gonna be a lot of revenue that a lot of
value created so I have a sense about
revenue per order likewise I can guess
some things about the conversion rate so
for example I know the expensive things
generally harder to sell they generally
have a low conversion rate like people
just need a bit more reassurance and
also people just like to click on
expensive properties to see what
expensive properties look like so it
expects it to have less than the average
conversion rate but it's probably not
gonna be too bad like that's a fantastic
set of reviews it looks genuinely very
pretty and it's exactly where I want it
to be so I guess this can be around like
the middle of the second quarter
somewhere in that territory and by
breaking convert em for revenue per
click up into conversion rate and
revenue per order I can take something I
knew nothing about and converts it into
a factor factorization things I do know
about
and we could continue this like almost
indefinitely we could take revenue per
order and break into number of nights
and revenue per night
we could take number of room nights and
break that into number of rooms in the
number of nights and Sun and Sun and
from an engineering point of view it
makes sense to try and stay as high on
this as possible so like you start off
up here and if you have compelling
evidence that you're going to gain an
advantage from breaking it down you
would do that and we're probably now at
the point where we're starting to build
compelling evidence we want to move down
again and as soon as you find the right
factorization of your model everything
becomes so much easier you can go from
having this just nollie mess of a
distribution so a really nice log normal
camera and to a binomial kind of
distribution so this is nice just to
look at but it also means you have
access to a lot of standard tooling so
most statistical packages will be able
to do politians
of rates classifications and standard
progressions whereas they're not set up
to deal with this kind of distribution
this makes diagnosing models better and
monitoring the production much easier
but more than that this new flood of
domain knowledge allowed our model
progresses to just boom we suddenly have
loads of ideas those of hypotheses about
how to make it better and we also knew
there were domain experts across the
business we could go and talk to if we
ever ran out and needed more so this was
probably I think I think the best
decision that we made in the whole
process although not necessarily
applicable to your problems so unto
problem 4 and at this point you know
what I think we actually had solved it
like everything was looking pretty
peachy at this point progressions
happening quite nicely and at a high
level it looks something like this we'd
have our data once a month we'd retain
our models we'd update all of our
estimates and then we'd have a lot of
humans that loop domain experts with a
lot of experience doing this whose job
was to fold it was to take into account
things that had happened since the last
time that we trained model
so say we enter our period of
seasonality conversion rate increases
we're gonna need to push everything up
and the second was to try and correct
things to muddle go run so we try our
best we build good models but
occasionally they're not going to be
right and it's useful to have someone
who has the expertise to push it up and
do the oil Corrections but now I'm
looking at this my ego is boosted by all
the successes I've been having recently
maybe were a barb ever drunken boast and
like you know what I can get rid of
those humans in the loop I'm a data
scientist right they're gonna follow
some kind of broad algorithm so I can
codify it I can replicate it I can scale
it I can make you better and I come up
with this so there's no need for people
to be responding to changes in
distribution right why trying the model
once a month when I can just train it
once a day computes cheap it's gonna
power it through and they're still going
to be some need for occasional
Corrections modeling really perfect so
I'm gonna have some kind of feedback
loop like a ped controller which is
going to do a lot of what humans are
doing before but finally I'm not quite
so egotistical I believe that I can get
rid of the humans entirely right there's
always gonna be that edge case but very
where their domain expertise is gonna
allow them to be the model so I'm still
gonna have them here but like they're
only going to intervene in like real
special cases and maybe already you can
kind of start to see where this is going
wrong so we've got so many red lines
coming down from the data deep into the
process and we've also taken one box and
like shattered that into three different
places uh indeed this was catastrophic
and since then we've completely like
ditch this it was a good like three
months of development there was a waste
of time and the issue was that we now
saw much lower levels of attention for
human operators whereas before they were
looking very deeply at everything every
day like there was just less need to do
that now right so data scientists come
see you they say look I've got this
model this algorithm it's going to do
this great thing you're just not going
to check over a shelter that much the
second is that we saw a lot of bad
decisions on when to act so this might
either have been - showing the model too
much respect not Stepien
should do or in the spin waiting too
long and stepping in only when the model
had corrected itself so you had this
wild oscillating swing of performance
and finally just mechanically the
interventions for worse we saw a lot
more times where people wanted to do
something but because he hadn't done it
in a while they just forgotten how to do
it or they did it wrong and that just
led to problems and confusion so it was
really nasty really bad and the solution
is to go back and to think about what
made the original design work so it
might not be flashy it might not be
fancy but he did have an incredibly
clear handoff of responsibility what was
the job of the model versus what was the
job of the human was very clearly Demark
who had the final decision was never in
down the model updated once a month and
then handed over to the humans total
Authority but it was also a problem was
just very well suited to human operators
there's a very clear conceptual model if
I'm seeing that my return on investment
is too high and that my volumes at you
low I push everything up and if I see
you the reverse I pull everything down
it's a simple model and it's also one
that is very easy to get feedback on
because I'm the only person acting this
system if I push everything you up by
five percent I see how much production I
get the next day I can then learn
something about like the elasticity's
and how the system responds and then I
can iteratively keep making decisions
the final nice thing is the consistent
use to paraphrase Machiavelli makes for
great human operators being forced to
use this every day develops a real sense
of ownership and also just a great sense
of expertise so that when you do reach
these occasions where extreme actions
are needed where your model is failing
on edge cases you've got people who are
well trained in the domain by contrast
this approach is awful on every one of
these there is no clear handle from
Authority if I see the production is bad
is that the job of the daily model
training it's the job of the fee but
live or is it my job as a human and when
do I as a human get the con when can I
make the decision against the machine
it's not not at all clear
and there's also very little in the way
of clear timely feedback so if I push by
5% and then everything else in the
system is doing different things how do
i disambiguate my my actions from the
actions of the r4 system and finally
people were just not being gun asked to
do this very often so when they came to
do it they didn't have that training
there were novices in the system being
thrown in right at the deep end let's
get outside
so the solution ultimately I came up
with could have looked like this well
this is still way too fancy I try to
explain and get in my practice
presentations and I couldn't I have to
admit that we ultimately just went back
to this worked well what's my system so
those were their four main types of
failures that I had along the way if I
could leave you with some parting
thoughts it's the the problems that we
try to solve are difficult it's easy to
look at blog posts and videos and like
courses online and think the data
science is easy but you can just take
some data and throw it into an algorithm
and get good results but the reality is
that following this fairytale will lead
you to failures it's really important in
our jobs in our domain that we think
deeply about our models why we're trying
to build them what we want them to do
are they achieving those goals and in
what contexts the operating and this way
we can build successful models
[Applause]
all right we have some time for
questions if you'll require hands up and
you can pick the people if you want to
what extent what you have an
automatically trained model are you just
in an arms race against your competitors
who also have automatically trained
models and you get some sort of feedback
loop does that happen it does at times
feel like trying to play football
manager or something on those lines I've
done that but I mean the reality is that
we're not actually competing against
each other so there are customers who is
very well suited to Expedia and there
are customers which are very well suited
to hotels calm and then their customers
while suited to other people and it's
like through time as these tools get
more sophisticated
it's about finding for the right
customer the right place to go and we do
spend a fair amount of time on that okay
yeah like in stock trading models you
wonders that problem what about you
trying your model and then that it gets
worse because it's like there you have
one homogeneous commodity whereas here
we have lots of different people with
different intentions like different
preferences anybody else okay he's a
very cool jokes thank you how would you
discuss it if it's like your higher
level stakeholders to acknowledge
failure to them what do they think about
it did you get promoted because of this
success and feathers or wise first so I
think the main thing to dealing with
stakeholders is like you build trust
through a long period of time so you can
encounter these failures but if they see
you like on a Saturday morning owning up
to making mistake and making it right
and fixing it like that's a big thing
and like if they see that is kind of
finding my mistakes right everyone's
gonna make mistakes particularly in this
very difficult domain but there is this
idea of data scientist is being feckless
and disinterested in two entities
showing things and if you can show that
you're not that I think it's quite easy
to build deep relationships with your
stakeholders
anybody else this answer your question
thank you so I think the whole area of
kind of modern risk management and when
do you want a human to step in and kind
of override the decisions of the model
is really interesting there's obvious
applications in financial trading for
war and all kinds of other industries
did you and hotels.com feel like there
was a kind of body of knowledge you were
looking at or were you kind of were you
just kind of making it up as you go
along sorry I don't mean that so to
start with I was definitely making it
worse I went along but because you like
you're trying things here it's racing
and you're working closely with the
human operators you can see what works
for you I think a point of inflection
that I had that led me to some of my
biggest realizations was actually
industrial process theory it's a lot of
like nuclear plant studying where
catastrophes happen in industrial plants
and like a lot of the themes that I had
up on here we're basically starting from
that kind of sector in general it's
really fascinating stuff airplanes as
well like the disasters that they have
and like the inspections into why that
happened we have time for one or two
more anybody
so what I loved about this talk is
people admit that sometimes stuff goes
wrong and that doesn't happen well
enough and will be kind of nice if maybe
there were like resources and more
stories like this would you happen to
have maybe one or two like I'm not sure
if there's a book about this sort of
thing but maybe you know like a resource
that's an excellent question one of the
reasons I wanted to give this talk is
because I wanted to have received this
talk when I came to by day two years ago
I know that in academia there's this
trend now it's like a and CV or
something like that what you list the
big valleys you've got I'm not aware of
anything in the data science community
in the same way but no sorry I've lived
here see any if you find any on your way
very quick question all this process
what was the time scale of this how long
did it take from the beginning to the
end just an embarrassingly huge amount
of life so from the first meeting that
was about two years ago so like the
opening phase was quite fast where I
felt everything was going great and then
there was like a long one year stretch
for it was catastrophic the awful like
everything takes so much longer than you
expect it to do anybody else yeah I have
a question out of all the four failures
which one had the biggest negative
impacts would you say that's a good
question it's like the worst failures
you identify really quickly so hyper
optimizing pharmacy like you deceived by
very bad model I think this was the
worst one because it was very insidious
very long-term you built up this great
set of people to work with human experts
and like you're just slowly every week
degrading their trust in you but also
like you're removing this well-trained
aspect to them and then sudden you've
got new pupils coming into the company
and they've never had this good regime
and all they know is to bide regime and
that's really hard to reverse anybody
else okay thank you very much
you